host has become the bonehead of the week
i don't know what the hell is going on
but um gabe howard how are you gabe what
what's going on over there what what
uh uh can you hear me hi this is uh this
is twitter technical support oh okay
twitter are you there i i'm here can you
see me i i can see you yes okay great
great great yeah so uh we've been
experiencing some outages this morning i
just wanted to report uh i saw some
calls come in
and uh today i am your uh tech support
so
just wanted to make sure uh twitter was
up and running for you i know it was
down for some people but i want to make
sure that you know for twitter users uh
we are taking care of you
well good i'm i'm glad you're with us
because we were having some trouble
earlier um and i think i think even the
hashtag twitterdown is is trending now
if on on the platform that is still
going oh we'll make sure to suppress
that right away do you
do you want me to pull that up so you
can see that cert let's see that sure
sure they don't they don't let us surf
twitter at work so okay here here is the
uh twitter down um feed
oh yeah we're gonna have to bring this
one down yeah you might have a request
to suppress this right now yeah okay
well yeah yeah you might wanna you might
wanna say something about the uh and
then the hashtag if you're wondering
here is twitter
down that's hashtag i think it's because
because twitter's
not working i don't know what and what
regions of the twitterverse are not
working uh that is privileged
information oh okay i'm just here to
make sure i'm just here to make sure
that uh you're good to go and we do not
discuss the fact that twitter is down
but rather that twitter is up
yeah well twitter seems to be
up but the hashtag twitter down seems to
be
up as well i mean i'm just it's turning
at number three
okay
[Music]
hold on hey yeah kill it kill it uh-huh
are you unplugging twitter are you on
what i'm sorry what was that what are
you saying twitter sorry sir it looks
like there's a bad connection here um
what hey can you hear me hello hello can
you can you hear me over at twitter i
yes i can hear you yes okay twitter down
is it seems to still be trending i don't
know if you turned it off or not i said
[ __ ] killer yeah it's it's it's it's
at number two now it's getting better
like it's it's moving up the it's moving
up the trend down up down
um yeah twitter is down no twitter no
twitter is down
um yep anyway uh just want to make sure
that you're good to go and twitter is
working for you sir uh
twitter is perfect i think i think we'll
be able to manage at this point we are
going to go to
bonehead of the week so let's start
bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
oh welcome back to the show for bonehead
of the week
hey gabe how are you whoa hey what's
going on just got out of the shower what
oh did you okay well that's that's good
that's good did you see did you see this
guy uh you come on the uh what come on
the screen you're well we had to call
twitter that there's twitter support um
that's that is crazy what are you
talking about well you know it you know
twitter was down earlier um it's
trending actually oh was it yeah i just
i just woke up i just got out of the
shower yeah yeah
trending number two twitter is down it
was down it actually went down while i
was on the show wow some people still
have
tweets that that sucks that's yeah that
doesn't work
you know what you know what it really
sucks for when we do bonehead of the
week because we like rely on twitter
right to do the production
luckily uh whoever your support person
was
if i had to assume
they uh they came and they fixed
problems so now we're we're on twitter
right we're on we we have twitter for
now oh for now right now rather it now
how long it would be up or down i guess
is the is the question um they were
really upset over there at twitter
um because the trend down was trending
up and they want to not have it down but
up right right you know you get you get
the yeah you want twitter up but they
don't want they want the trend down not
up it's kind of confusing yeah i you
know what if i had to assume i'm pretty
sure there was some confusion because
they they're they've been testing the uh
down vote upvote
uh oh yeah you know so
i haven't seen that much is that is that
for us here or is this in different
regions that they have no we have it i
i've seen it around basically uh you can
downvote stuff so it's like you know
trying to be like reddit right so can
you download the downvote can you do
that
no you can only downvote comments
oh oh so it's not actually tweets
yeah yeah you can i mean well
technically they're all tweets tony you
know oh jesus you can down vote a
comment i don't think you can down vote
is it a comment or is it a reply because
it says reply it doesn't say okay fine
we'll call it a reply you know what
semantics okay i'm just saying i'm just
saying replies just trying to
call i mean we can call the tech support
guy back if we want sure yeah if you
want to call him up i'm sure he would
love to speak maybe we could maybe
he could call back we could ask him
comment reply comment reply well let's
let's get into the bonus of the week
we're we're 23 minutes into the second
hour right um what do you think of our
bone ends this week